una celda de concentración es una celda
que tienen los mismos electrodos de
ambos lados así que del lado izquierdo
nosotros tenemos un electrodo de zinc
mientras que del lado derecho tenemos
también un electrodo de zinc la única
diferencia es la concentración del lado
izquierdo tenemos una solución con una
concentración de 0.10 molar y esto es
una solución de sulfato de zinc mientras
que del lado derecho tenemos la misma
solución pero a una concentración de 1.0
molar muy bien así que el lado izquierdo
tiene una menor concentración vamos a
escribir eso tiene una menor
concentración mientras que el lado
derecho tiene una mayor concentración
muy bien y hay cierta tendencia de las
concentraciones a digamos ser igualadas
muy bien y eso es eso será suficiente
para crear un pequeño voltaje así que
como podríamos hacer que estas
concentraciones digamos queden un poco
más parejas así que vamos a enfocarnos
primero en el lado izquierdo que es en
donde tenemos una menor concentración y
donde tenemos una menor concentración
pues en realidad necesita
más concentrada así que puede hacer esto
al aumentar la concentración de iones de
5-2 positivo en la solución muy bien y
como podríamos incrementar esta esta
concentración de 52 positivo bueno eso
ocurre si el zinc sólido se convierte en
millones de 5-2 positivos verdad eso
incrementa la concentración de zinc dos
positivos entonces este esté zinc sólido
se convierte en iones de 5 2 positivo y
eso sabemos que es una digamos un
fenómeno de oxidación verdad así que del
lado izquierdo tenemos oxidación lo que
ocurre es una oxidación vamos a escribir
eso aquí tenemos que del lado izquierdo
hay un hay una oxidación y es del zinc
sólido que se convierte en
2 positivos iones de 5 2 positivo verdad
y voy a voy a poner explícitamente que
nos estamos refiriendo a él digamos a la
concentración 0.1 molar verdad para que
será para que sea un poco más claro y
por supuesto para que esto ocurra en
realidad lo que está pasando es que está
perdiendo dos electrones muy bien lo que
ocurre con esos dos electrones es que se
mueven digamos hacia este cable que
tenemos por acá arriba ok y entonces
esto empieza a generar una corriente
ahora pensemos en el lado que tiene una
mayor concentración muy bien vámonos del
lado derecho y pensemos qué es lo que va
a ocurrir bueno necesitamos ahora que
este lado más concentrado disminuya su
concentración verdad y eso necesita
digamos que por ejemplo disminuya la
concentración de 52 positivo en esta
solución así que como lograríamos que el
52 positivo disminuya su concentración
bueno eso ocurre si por ejemplo gana
electrones
para formar zinc sólido y nosotros ya
sabemos que eso es una reducción verdad
así que del lado derecho ocurre un
fenómeno digamos de reducción vamos a
poner así el red aunque red de reducción
voy a escribir lo mejor reducción muy
bien vamos a escribirlo aquí abajo la
reducción en que consistiría bueno
tendríamos zinc digamos está se
encuentra la concentración 1.0 molar
verdad para que haya una reducción
tendrá que ganar dos electrones y por
supuesto este eran éstos eran iones de
52 positivo que al ganar dos electrones
se convierten en zinc sólido
ahora bien pensemos en la reacción total
qué ocurre la reacción total será
digamos sumar estas dos reacciones
aunque pensemos en la reacción total y
podemos observar lo siguiente estos 2
electrones se cancelan con los dos
electrones que tenemos del lado derecho
y también podemos ver que el zinc sólido
aparece tanto del lado izquierdo como
del lado derecho entonces también
podemos cancelarlo
reacción total que obtenemos es la
siguiente tendremos zinc 2 positivo como
reactivo verdad a una concentración de
1.0 molar verdad y eso nos produce como
digamos como producto un 5-2 positivo a
concentración 0.10 molar muy bien la
pregunta ahora es cómo encontramos el
voltaje de nuestra celda de
concentración y recordemos de los
últimos vídeos que la ecuación del ernst
nos permite calcular el potencial de la
celda muy bien así que vamos a hacer un
poco de espacio para poder escribir la
ecuación tener en verdad y recordemos
rápidamente que la ecuación del mnr nos
dice que el potencial de la celda es
igual al potencial de la celda estándar
menos 0.05 92 dividido entre n donde n
es el número de moles de electrones que
son transferidos en la reacción cierto y
eso hay que multiplicarlo por el
logaritmo
y esta es una de las formas que tiene la
ecuación del mes que vimos en los vídeos
anteriores verdad así que primero
pensemos en qué ocurre con la ley con la
variable q y en este caso nos
preguntamos bueno cuál será el valor de
la variable q y recordemos que esto
sería digamos la concentración de 52
positivos pero en este caso corresponde
al 5 con menor concentración es decir lo
que se encuentra del lado izquierdo de
la celda dividido entre 5 2 positivo
pero del lado donde se encuentra con
mayor concentración verdad entonces
recordemos que esto sería igual a bueno
si la concentración de 52 positivo
cuando había una menor concentración
sería 0.10 molar verdad esto sería
punto 10 molar dividido entre 1.0 verdad
esto sería el valor de q para este para
esta reacción digamos que tenemos aquí
con esto ahora pensemos en el potencial
de celda verdad bueno pensemos primero
en el potencial de celda estándar que
sería es 0 muy bien pensemos ahora en es
0 cuál sería el potencial de celda
estándar en este caso bueno recordemos
que el potencial de celda estándar es el
potencial bajo condiciones estándar
cierto así que vamos a escribir las semi
reacciones de reducción y de oxidación
en este caso y nosotros tenemos que el
área la semi reacción de reducción sería
ésta que tenemos aquí sería
2 positivo verdad 1.0 molar verdad + 2
electrones eso nos produce zinc sólido
muy bien y si nos fijáramos digamos en
alguna tabla de valores de potencial de
reducción estándar nos daríamos cuenta
que el valor del potencial de reducción
estándar para esta semi reacción
equivale a menos 0.76 volts muy bien
ahora si pensamos en la reacción en la
semi reacción de oxidación tendremos
zinc sólido verdad que nos produce zinc
2 positivo
racing 2 positivo +2 electrones 2
electrones
nuevamente recordemos cómo obtener el
potencial de oxidación estándar para
este caso simplemente tendremos que
fijarnos en el valor de la semi reacción
contraria verdad que sería justamente la
que tenemos arriba entonces el potencial
de oxidación estándar será exactamente
el mismo que teníamos en el caso
anterior pero con el signo contrario
entonces aquí tendríamos más 0.76 volts
y esto ya lo hemos hecho varias veces en
vídeos anteriores para calcular el
potencial de la celda el potencial
estándar tendremos simplemente que sumar
ambos potenciales el de reducción y el
de oxidación y entonces si nos damos
cuenta en realidad son los mismos
números pero con signo contrario lo cual
nos dice que el potencial de es el de
estándar vale cero muy bien el potencial
de celda estándar vale cero y es este
valor el que vamos digamos a sustituir
en la ecuación detenernos muy bien así
que vamos a sustituir todo lo que ya
tenemos en la ecuación del mnr para
calcular el potencial de celda
muy bien entonces qué es lo que
tendremos que el potencial de celda
será igual al potencial de celda
estándar que en este caso es 0 menos
0.05 92 dividido entre n pero recordemos
quienes n n es el número de moles de
electrones que son transferidos en la
reacción y podemos observar que son dos
moles muy bien entonces esto lo
dividimos entre dos y multiplicamos por
el logaritmo de q que en este caso hemos
observado que es 0.10 0.10 dividido
entre 1.0 y ahora lo que nos queda es
calcular todas estas operaciones esto
simplemente será 0 menos 0.5 92
podríamos calcular primero calculemos el
logaritmo tendremos el logaritmo de 0.10
dividido dividido entre 1.0 verdad y eso
nos da esta respuesta que es menos 1 y
menos 1 tendrá que multiplicar
menos 0.05 92 verdad dividido entre 2
entonces esto multiplica a menos 0.05 92
verdad y eso lo dividimos entre 2 y nos
da una respuesta de 0.02 96 muy bien
tendremos entonces que el potencial de
celda es 0.02 96 volts este es el valor
de potencial de celda y algo que podemos
observar es que este valor es positivo
verdad lo cual nos dice que esto ocurre
de forma espontánea y este podría ser
digamos el voltaje de la celda
instantáneo verdad el voltaje
instantáneo así que cuando estamos
hablando de estas concentraciones en
realidad estamos hablando de las
concentraciones que tenemos en este
preciso momento que es verdad que sería
0.1
1.0 y justo cuando tenemos esas
concentraciones tenemos un pequeño
voltaje verdad es positivo y es muy
pequeño pero esto simplemente se debe a
la diferencia de las concentraciones
verdad así que qué ocurre digamos cuando
las concentraciones se van aproximando
verdad cuando estas concentraciones que
tenemos aquí estas concentraciones que
tenemos aquí se van aproximando bueno ya
hemos visto que q debería aumentar
verdad lo cual significa que el
potencial de celda va a tener que
disminuir cierto por otro lado si
pensamos que es lo que ocurre cuando las
concentraciones son iguales entonces
digamos vamos a regresar a esta parte en
donde hemos definido el quien era q
verdad y entonces si las concentraciones
son iguales estamos pensando que esta
concentración y esta de abajo son
iguales concluimos que el valor de q es
exactamente 1
así que vamos vamos a escribir eso
verdad vamos a escribir eso cuando
cuando las concentraciones las
concentraciones
centra ciones son iguales cuando las
concentraciones son iguales es decir
estamos pensando que el valor de q es
igual a 1 entonces lo que vamos a tener
que hacer es calcular el logaritmo de 1
verdad es decir el potencial de celdas
será 0 menos 0.05 92 dividido entre 2
por el logaritmo de 1 pero nosotros
sabemos que el logaritmo de 1 vale 0
verdad y 0 por este número valdrá 0 y
concluimos que el potencial de celda es
igual a 0 y esto tiene mucho sentido
verdad porque si las concentraciones son
iguales entonces no hay ninguna
tendencia de las concentraciones digamos
a igualarse así que no vamos a tener
como consecuencia un voltaje producido